on the hills of the city of viin Delmar
the destruction that began on Friday
night is impossible to
quantify there was the kitchen the
bathroom and the dining
room friends relatives and total
strangers volunteer to help residents
clear the rubble left by the
wildfires in Margarita viag Gran's case
from a three-story home where she also
ran a grocery shop but she considers
herself
lucky my neighbor's father my
daughter-in-law's two parents the three
children of a colleague all of them burn
to death it's
unbearable the stench of death is still
strong here when the fire hit this
neighborhood many people rushed to their
vehicles to try to escape but there's
only one narrow road in and out of this
area and so very soon the traffic was
absolutely paralyzed leaving many people
to die sitting in their cars unable to
move the Region's Governor is angry and
tells Al jazer that this was a man-made
tragedy a handful of miserable monsters
caus this who came to destroy our city
we will hunt them down and imprison them
because they caused more than fires
these were
murders at the morg sorrow and shock
accompany those waiting for the remains
of their loved ones to be released for
burial among them two sisters who lost
their mother and 17-year-old Trinidad
who died trying to save
her I know that my daughter was a
heroine because she never abanded my
mother and her grandmother they were
found together their budes in an
ESS but there are hundreds of more
presumed victims yet to be found so many
have come to provide DNA samples hoping
that forensic teams will be able to find
an identify their missing loved ones
Lucia Newman Al jazer valpariso region
Chile make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer